[Musique]
c'est un workshop concours qui s
intitule imaginer le visage énergétique
du futur du plateau de saclay ve dans
les locaux de centrale supélec un
workshop qui est clos disciplinaire et
qui rassemble du coup une diversité de
l'étudiant qui viennent de plus d'une
dizaine d'écoles donc parisienne mais
bien au delà aussi l'idée de ce workshop
concours c'est de mobiliser sur une
question de valorisation de la
transition énergétique les savoir faire
et compétences pour rendre cette
transition énergétique effective et
désirable l'idée c'est de lier des
savoir-faire paysagiste de design
d'architecturé mais aussi d'ingénierie
et puis il ya aussi d'autres d'autres
formations qui peut agronomie
urbanistique aussi aussi représenter ces
étudiants deviennent des différentes
écoles que sont notamment l'école
d'architecturé de versailles
l'école de paysages l'école centrale
supélec qui nous accueille aujourd'hui
et puis les différentes écoles de design
et d'art s'ils sont présents sur parions
donc l'initiative de ce workshop a été
permise par la rencontre entre les
directeurs du land art generator
initiative qui est un concours
d'architecturé bisannuel et la chaire
paysage énergie de l'école de paysage de
versailles de la diagonale paris-saclay
donc qui allie art et science sur le
campus universitaire une somme le design
center
et puis évidemment centrale supélec
l'idée à l'issue de ce workshop c'est
que les groupes étudiants puissent
produire des représentations de cette
transition énergétique dans un contexte
territorial qui est celui du plateau de
saclay sont des propositions qui doit
être aussi ambitieuse puisqu'elle leur
aussi être révélatrice de cette
transition
c'est une réussite de pouvoir faire sans
montrer également
les enseignants et les institutions à
travers ce workshop qui font que puisse
y avoir de nouvelles collaborations qui
puisse créer et rendu des étudiants sont
pour l'allemand source d'inspiration
pour l'élaboration du pca et et du plan
climat air énergie territorial en cours
d'élaboration actuellement avec la
communauté d'agglomération paris saclay
[Musique]